today i am lending my infinite wisdom
towards ready that's right ask reddit
where you can ask
anything except i answer and you guys
can play along as well
what is your opinion on these topics i
want to know
for example how the after you make
friends as an adult
if you don't drink get better friends i
don't know
why should they care if you drink or not
i have friends that don't drink it it's
like whatever
great sure who cares this is what reddit
says
slowly hobbies community involvement
get the [ __ ] out get out of here get out
of here
community you guys really struggling
that much to get friends
volunteering i feel like when you're a
teenager that's when there's more
pressure for you to drink right
am i missing something here well not
when you're an adult
elon musk is now worth 197
built how do we sell him
how do we harvest him that's what
everyone's trying to figure out
we make him go on meme review and then
we
i don't know buy tesla stock i don't
think you know what's cool now but
probably won't be in five years
tick tock please i you know five years
that's too long
yeah they make it five months nah it's
too long let's see what reddit thinks
probably most youtubers as of now
how dare you hey ten years and i'm still
running
okay you read it it's a miracle
pewdiepie and markiplier have survived
as long as they have
[Music]
what are some green flags early on in
dating that the relationship
should be serious well normally or
typically one of you say i love you and
the other person says
i love i love you too and then that's
usually a great indicator
well let's see what i've read it says
early in our dating days
i was on a train with my now husband the
inspector was checking out our tickets
while we were about to pull away from
the station
when my husband spotted a woman come
running down the platform
he pointed this out to the inspector who
stuck
his arm out the window and held the
train until she got on
and that's when i knew that our
relationship
was gonna work out
this reminds me of my what is this he
always offer to help people with heavy
bags
that does not mean you're compatible as
people what the [ __ ]
am i missing something i get it's nice
to have a husband who's kind to other
people
on strangers but that's such a min what
i feel so disconnected from this if an
alien offered you
a one week trip across the galaxy and
back with the catch being 15 years
passes on earth would you accept or
reject the offer and why
well let me tell you all i want to know
i don't care about
aliens i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care
about all the planets to my mammals i
just want to i need to know
is tyne infinite is it circular or
past finite that's all i want to know
now
on the basis that it takes 15 years to
go to the other side of the galaxy or
not it doesn't take 15 to 40 years to
pass on earth
and time is relative we know that for
sure by logic
then we should be able to calculate how
big the galaxy is that way
calculate other things about time i'm
sure if i sat down i could figure out
so i don't need the trip you just
answered it [ __ ]
that's what i say to the alien huh you
just played yourself
fool you fool idiot
you reveal the secrets of the universe
and i didn't even have to go
i use math and logic and i haven't done
yet
see that's some animation got him i feel
really good about that answer let's see
what dumbass
reddit said
check to see if my job will be okay with
a 15 year
okay people who don't get stressed
during a presentation school or work
what's your secret
that's a good question experience yeah i
think reddit nailed it on this one
i used to get nervous and now i don't
not sure when or why that happened
well it's not just experience i mean if
you go in every time
to a presentation getting nervous and
you don't change your behavior or
your response then yeah you're always
gonna get nervous but if you go into
these situations with the mindset and
rationale like
understanding that no this isn't going
to kill me everything will be fine
regardless of the outcome
and you reinforce that every single time
then yes through experience you will
then have learned
to not get as nervous as you used to be
so it's not just experience it's also
how you meet these experiences and and
staying consistent with
it huh you're welcome you're welcome
reddit
what would 12 year old you never believe
about adulthood
i can't think of anything you're telling
me i get to
play video games for a living i can play
as much video games as i want
and i get paid no i don't believe it
that's [ __ ]
i have the 12 year old dream job
basically come on
i don't even get to play as much games
as i want now but in future i
play forever wow
people have stories they want to share
but have not found a question relevant
to them what are your stories
well you see i took a [ __ ] in the shower
once
that's it your parents and media were
right
video games do cause violence based on
the last game you played what are you
getting arrested for
i don't wrote my parents into this okay
they are not dumb like that
but minecraft i think it's pretty
obvious i will have to answer for my
crimes of killing watersheep at last
i think that's fair arrest me at right
now
what's something you'd love to see but
won't be alive for nothing
there's nothing that excites me about
the future only pain and misery lies
ahead
what is technology going to do for me at
this point that it hasn't already been
able to do
the days of the free human spirits are
gone for five minutes you get
transported 30 years into the future you
sit in front of the computer
what information would you look up well
isn't the obvious one lottery bets
huh am i the only one who always try to
look how i can monetize something
it's my it's in my blood i'm a youtuber
i can't help it
oh people looked up like what historical
bad events we should avoid and i just
went straight to the lottery
what's something you should always keep
in your car first aid kit
i win i win i win
i got the moral points on that one
something you should keep in a car first
aid kit let's see if anyone says it
if you travel with your dog a bottle of
water
and a drinking ball well that's a bit
circumstantial don't you
i think that was not the question you
don't it wasn't
if you traveled with your dog what's
something you should bring with you
idiots fools you're fools you need me
reddit just say it
my truck has at least three days of
worth of food for my dog at all times
no one asked no one asked anything from
you
you can just leave you had nothing the
door is right there [ __ ]
skedaddle a fire extinguisher nah
i stand by my answer what is
surprisingly safe for human consumption
well apparently anything
as an avid viewer of my strange
obsession they're all fine
mattress sand drywall i don't know
how these people are alive that's a joke
by the way do not eat any of those
that's very harmful for you
what would happen if all seven billion
people screamed at once what is this a
cursed gods video
i'm curious now cough drop sales would
increase for a week
nice nothing sound decays too quickly to
have any kind of combined application
effect
right it will all be centralized to the
area it wouldn't just
all accumulate into this one giant ball
of
super saiyan wrestling i don't know what
tv show was amazing at first but became
unwatchable for you later on
well any tv show with a plot twist right
if you know the plot twist coming it's
like i don't know
what famous person did you regret
meeting because they were an ass
okay we're good we're good is it weird
that i want all the celebrities side of
this
like jimmy fallon flipped some guy off i
want to i want to hear from jilly fowl
and what happened
right i was the ass okay here we go i
saw don
sierra where the [ __ ] is that oh okay
and what happened i was thinking about
ocean's 11 and said to my friend
dude it's bernie mac and he looked back
and said no i'm the other black guy
promotions 11
but at least you like the movie
damn damn
damn that's funny
leto hit on my girlfriend at the time
and called me fat
his brother shannon was super nice
though jared leto again i sat next to
him in a flight
absolute [ __ ] jared leto i worship
him as a teenager
wrecking with a dream but he was the
most pretentious arrogant person in real
life never meet your heroes
dude four people four feet people that's
hilarious
no replies if you're an adult what's
something you are never truly too old
for i guess playing video games right
coloring no what's your comfort movie
the room has such a vibe to it i it
makes me happy
men have read it who are your female
heroes i'll
watch everyone say their grandma or mom
all right
yeah i pretended to be xena all the time
as a kid
i mean i have very few people i look up
to in history as well
so and most of them are authors and
there's not many
old female authors so i don't know the
odds are stacked against you
my mother my grandmother my sister
my wife my daughter shut up
have some ideals okay not just who you
saw in your life being a good person
well that means
nothing get out of here i'm joking by
the way my mom is actually a huge
inspiration for me
yeah i guess that's what i'll have to go
with what's the worst mistake people
don't realize that they're making in
their 20s
that being an adult [ __ ] sucks so spend
your youth
as much as you can like okay you're in
school for like what
your entire childhood right and then
you're free and it's like a rush to get
a job or an education it's like bruh
just chill
oh my god same answer life is not a race
yeah it seemed like it oh this person
has already got a job and they already
got blood and it's like
dude what can just eff up me
with this video that was fun hope that
was interesting i hope you guys enjoyed
if you did remember to pop that like
button and
make sense out of that subscribe button
and i'll see you guys tomorrow
later